let's take a look at a city that uh is
under the the rule of policies like this
we have the story for the daily mail san
francisco mayor london breed claims
walgreens is only shutting five stores
to cut costs
but pharmacy chains as it spends nearly
50 times as much on security as stores
in that city compared to anywhere else
all right let's slow down
san francisco has such crime because uh
i mean people are just going into
walgreens shuffling stuff into bags one
guy's on a bike he's running off a
garbage bag full of stuff and so
walgreens says
we're going to shut down several stores
it's happened with other stores target
reduced hours this is partly due to the
fact that the city basically said
anything 900 or under won't be
prosecuted yep so people are like free
free free run i guess here's the best
part
london breed is claiming walgreens is
only shutting five stores to cut costs
why would walgreens need to cut costs
it's a it's a a grocery store and
pharmacy in a major urban center of tens
of millions of people in the entirety of
the bay area so uh
wouldn't what why why why is something
what is happening in san francisco where
they're like we can't afford this
anymore well the cost of security
apparently
watching they've done it such that
there's these videos where the security
guard has to stand there and watch them
loot the place because the police won't
back them up
so at some point to your point if it's
900 i don't know what cost more than 500
in walgreens right that's probably so
basically what they're saying is you can
loot the entire thing
i mean pretty much
and not face any consequences at some
point it's it's not worth it
think about it like can you name a
product in walgreens that's more than
900 but it's probably if they walk out
with more than 900 worth of stuff
but what happens is they come in with 10
of their friends and they all walk out
with 800 worth of stuff
right
there's videos of them walking up to the
makeup rack with bags and just shuffling
them all
and then there's that that one famous
video where the guy's on a bike in the
store just grabbing stuff and the
security guard's just filming watching
they can't do anything right it's what
they voted for if they want it yeah they
have it uh good for that that's right
but but also walgreens played by a
different set of rules especially during
the lockdowns walgreens was allowed to
be open so they made they made bank as
small mom-and-pop businesses got
obliterated and destroyed by policies
that prevented them from operating their
businesses and another reason why a lot
of people didn't want to be police
officers is because they got a lot of
hate not just from the left but also
from the right especially when they went
around small businesses and shut all of
them down while all the big
multinational corporations were able to
stay open so walgreens saying that the
need to save costs is bull crap they got
way more than enough money they got way
more than enough play within the federal
government that allowed them to stay
open during lockdown this is not
walgreens saying it they're being
accused by the mayor of san francisco of
cutting costs yeah walgreens is like
they're looting our stores to the point
we can't keep them open right and then
this is this is impacting people on on
many levels as well because a lot of
people can't even get their
prescriptions filled as well
so
i mean just a few years ago i remember
being in san francisco and it was like a
war zone out there so i mean this is
what people want this is what they voted
for uh good on you enjoy it
have fun when i when we had will
chamberlain and i think it was will and
charlie crook right yeah i think so they
uh i basically had a similar approach i
was like well if people vote for this
then let them have it and their response
was that's a very libertarian answer as
it said to me they said they're you know
they were conservatives and they feel
the law should be enforced equally for
all people the libertarians are the ones
who are like well if you vote for it
that's what you get
i thought that was a really really great
point we can't tolerate lawlessness in a
city even if people are they're not
voting for the crime they're voting for
policies that enable it right so the
crime still needs to be stopped well the
problem too though is let's face it if
you voted let's say you vote
you actually do vote because you want
lawlessness
but i don't should i have to bear the
consequences of someone's vote and
that's the problem is it san francisco
until it's a hundred percent you're
basically screwing everybody else who
wants to live there in peace and and uh
you know not have their stuff taken get
punched in the face
it's
the new
this is a great purge i mean think about
with the vax mandates you've got cops
who refuse to enforce or abide by are
quitting
law so law enforcement across the board
first responders military saying no to
this stuff officers resigning those who
can
and then you have in cities what's going
to happen maybe you're a moderate maybe
you're even a democrat and you hear
they're doing vax mandates and like you
said the polls show that most democrats
don't even agree with it they're going
to leave right they're going to move to
texas they're going to move to colorado
they're going to leave these heavily
blue areas making them even more heavily
blue exactly 100 i was going to say this
is the exact same problem you see with
the police force when the good officers
leave because they're like i will not
enforce something unconstitutional
you're left with police who will do
anything it's exactly the same in cities
if you force people who are moderate and
even remotely conservative out of your
city you're just going to end up with
seriously spiraling crime and like it
sounds great for them doesn't it
bill de blasio is like how do we get rid
of conservatives and moderates that's
just i know do things that are
unconstitutional and egregiously bad and
the democrats just accept it i guess
they're going to watch cnn we're good
yeah
stupid policy it doesn't equate as
liberalism to me i i don't know what
what these people are these and if it's
just like if it's just like endemically
idiotic and like addictive because like
they see one mayor do it another city on
the internet they're like i'm going to
try it now
they're responding to what tim was
talking about on the twitter example
that these guys think that somehow
that that vocal minority on twitter is a
majority and it's not and that's the
problem is that they think that they are
by by giving in to them that they are
doing the popular thing but they're just
giving into a very very loud minority
you know
i'll be interested to see what happens
in next year in the midterms because
we had this state seat in iowa flip
republican
there is some speculation for a lot of
reasons the republicans are going to
sweep in the house and maybe even the
senate
but i don't know man i'll i'll believe
it i'll tell you what i i'll take it one
step further
i think that if republicans just
literally
sat under a table and breathe for the
next whatever 13 months they will win
they need six seats they're going to get
two in texas because of the two new
districts they'll get one in florida and
there's a handful of others that are
easily flippable because they're
redistricting what i'm more interested
in is on january 7th 8th or whatever the
day that that new congress warns in
are the republicans especially in the
house going to put forward an agenda
that lit that is reflective of what the
people and the grassroots really have
asked for no absolutely no but
but that's my point right is that this
is what worries me is that finally
there's an opportunity never have the
lines been so clear this between
watching the difference between trump
and biden and watching the difference
between these mayors that we're all
talking about now if you don't get it
now you're never going to get it right
and so if republicans in the house
don't look at this opportunity and say
we got it
then that
they've blown it primaries i think i
think people got to make sure they're
paying attention to the republican
primaries and making sure establishment
do-nothing republicans
don't win i thought mike revell was
pushing this thing called the national
initiative that it would have given the
american people a fourth branch of
government they would have given us the
opportunity to write laws and pass them
into the senate i think that's a good
idea because these can these congress
people get in there and they get
desensitized and disassociated from what
regular people want and why why would we
not have the ability to pass laws anyway
i think this whole i mean there's this
is kind of there is the reference
process a lot of states have a
referendum process that functions that
way california switzerland has it as
well yeah
it's it's hard to say i do think
like you mentioned you know the
republicans they're historically due to
win um yes because of the unpopularity
of biden and we look at the historical
trends
but i'm just not convinced because like
you said if you don't get it now you're
never going to get it there are a lot of
people who are never going to get it now
there's a lot of reasons to think that
things might might flip interestingly in
the last election republicans
overperformed it was it was to the polls
it was crazy like miami going red yeah
south texas these all these areas
i want to believe
first i want to believe that republicans
will take back the house
and i would love to believe but i can't
that they would actually impeach joe
biden for like all the ukraine stuff and
i mean the dude's got literally
everything yeah not the emails that have
come out him meeting with hunter biden's
partners sharing bank accounts
is that every time
the only time that i've actually back if
you think back the only time they've
ever done anything effective is after 94
when there was a contract with america
and they said we're going to do these
things and for 100 days they did it and
then after it was like where do we go
but if they if they don't get it now
then i think that they're going to lose
trust for a really really long time i
don't know how you get it back because
enough of this stuff has happened and i
think that if what what i've started to
do is as i bring people on the show i'll
say are you committed to doing something
if you get back the majority because
they need to be held accountable yes and
that's that's the problem right now is
they're going to get a pass and i think
that we need to start what does that
agenda look like you know the problem is
if someone uh i'll start with this
republicans
when when polled have a negative view of
the republican party
democrats when polled have a positive
view of the democratic party
democrats watch cnn and they believe
everything they're told they watch
rachel maddow it is insane the amount of
lies pumped out through those networks
all day every day and people just
believe it even when it contradicts
itself bill i think a good example bill
maher even because he's been doing well
as a you know calling out the insanity
but he was wrong on the covington kids a
week after it happened because when you
just follow the cult media they have no
interest in informing you
now the problem here is
people are just going to blindly follow
mainstream media republicans won't
so if i go to someone on the right and
ask them a legitimate question and
they're honest about it they will get
destroyed in the media because they'll
be twisted and skewed and then you can
get someone you know in the bite
administration to literally break their
own rules like you know biden for
instance and they ignore it completely
so i i've been talking you know i talk
to regular people all the time i mean
just like you know going out going to
the hardware store people who don't know
who i am and just see how things are
going and a lot of them are like i have
no idea what's happening but they know
trump was bad that's all that's all they
know because they hear this stuff you
know from second hand but i told someone
today tim that imagine sitting in your
house
and turning on the television and
someone says it's raining
and to your point you trust it because
well the weather man is or a person is
on television saying it's raining but
then walking outside and being like wait
a second there's moisture coming down
and i'm getting wet that's what's
happening right now in america is that
we look
you turn on the morning shows or cnn
what have you and you are told certain
things
and you go well i'm supposed to believe
them because why would they lie or
mislead us
and yet they're not accurate you look at
what's happening right now with our
economy with afghanistan with all the
stuff that this administration tells us
and yet the mainstream media's
complicity in promoting the agenda and
the policies of this administration
is so corrupt
and it's so it's so undermining to the
professional journalism that it's
literally like sitting inside your house
and having someone tell you it's raining
on a sunny i mean it's sunny on a rainy
day have you ever i posted this photo on
instagram i can't pull it up unless i
log in but it shows i think it's like
cbs and fox news during gordon sandlin's
testimony and
they're two tv side by side in the gym
oh yeah i remember on one it says
sandlin confirms quid pro quo on fox
news it says sandlin confirms no quid
pro quo
amazing right how this happens and but
the funny thing is i wrote a post saying
fox is actually correct gordon sandlin
said trump told me there is no quid pro
quo but in his opinion he kind of felt
like there was one opinion is not
confirmation when the exact quote from
the president was don't right but
they'll frame it the way they want
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com timcast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you